♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est un grand mélange
d'émotions, hein, une
anticipation et une tristesse.
- Un mélange d'émotions fortes.
- Oui, oui, très fortes.
- C'est un jour historique
pour Robert Hackett. Aujourd'hui
âgé de 75 ans, cet avocat
de Montréal a cherché
toute sa vie à retrouver
des traces de son père.
- Ça dépasse tout ce que
j'aurais pu imaginer ou espérer.
- Aujourd'hui, pour la première
fois, il va naviguer tout prèsùe
chasse de son père s'est abîmé
le 31 mars 1951.
- Ce serait comme quasiment
un miracle de trouver ça, pouf!
Comme ça, d'un seul coup, hein.
Je pense que c'est le début
d'un processus.
- On a deux facteurs
à respecter : distance
et profondeur.
- Le capitaine du bateau
est Jean-Marc Perreault,
un passionisisisistoire
qui enseigne les sciences
au secondaire. C'est lui
le grand responsable de cette
aventure, qui vise à retrouver
lilililingue d'un avion
de l'armée canadienne...
- Il faut quand même se gard
une bonne zone de recherche.
- ... et peut-être les restes
de son pilote,
Guy Harding Hackett.
♪ ♪ ♪
Guy Hackett avait participé
à la deuxième grande gu
comme pilote de Mosquito,
un avion de chasse célèbre et
puissant. Ses missions au-dessus
du territoire allemand étaient
extrêmement aeseseseses...
- ... comme l'a découvert
son fils Robert des décennies
plus tard.
ROBERT HACKETT, fils du pilote
de guerre Guy Hackett
- L'idée, c'était d'intercepter
les avions allemands
qui rentraient atterrir chez
eux. Tout était en noirc
mais pour recevoir les avions,
ils allumaient. À ce moment-là,
les gars, vous y allez,
et vous essayez de fusiller.
Ça prenait des nerfs de fer,
ça prenait de l'audace.
Ça, c'est l'originala a a a a .
- Lors de sa dernière mission
en février 1945, l'avion
de Guy Hackett est touché
par des tirs de la défense
allemande...
- Ça, s'est le plan
des territoires où ils avaient
été capturés en Hollande.
- ... et fait prisonnier
par les nazis. Il sera libéré
cinq mois plus tard, à la fin
de la guerre, à l'âge de 26 ans.
- Il est revenu un homme...
complètement transformé,
qui buvait beaucoup, qui était
violent. C'était ce qu'on
en appelle aujourd'hui
post-traumatique, hein,
syndrome post-traumatique.
Regardez-moi ça!
- Dans les années qui suivent,
Guy Hackett se marie, devient
père et avocat. Il recommenc
à voler dans l'armée de réserve.
Il prend les commandes d'un
des premiers avions à réaction,
le Vampire. C'est à bord de cet
aéronef qu'il effect
d'entraînement au-dessus
du St-Laurent le jour fatidique.
- Ce matin-là, il y avait
un grand brouillard
et la n n n n n n n gars
qui a l'habitude de voler
à 25 pieds de la terre, là,
c'était : "On va passer
par en-dessous."
Et volant, son aile gauche
a touché l'eau et évidemment,
quand un bout de l'aile
d'un avion touche à 300 noeuds
à l'heure, c'est le désastre.
- Les avions, je les ai vus
passer; après ça, je les ai
perdus là.
- Jean Deguise avait 13 ans
à cette époque. Il est
probablement le dernier témoin
oculaire de l'accident.
- Ça me "pogne" au coeur.
- 70 ans plus tard,
il se rappelle bien de la scène,
des bancs de brouillard
qui obstruaient la vue
cet après-midi-là.
- J'ai vu les avions passer
une au-dessus de l'autre, puis
je savais que mon frère était
en bas. Il dit : "Jean,
les avions, as-tu entendu boum,
boum?" J'ai dit oui. Il dit :
"Ça, c'est une boule de feu."
- Le résident de Sorel
se souvient d'avoir récupéré
un réservoir à essence provenant
d'un des deux avions
que le courant avait transporté
devant chez lui.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Lorsqu'il ont fait leurs
recherches, l'eau était très
haute, fait que d'après moi,
l'eau était à la limite
du gazon.
- Les recherches menées par
les Forces canadiennes ont duré
une dizaine de jours. Le mauvais
temps, la présence de glaces
et la mauvaise visibilité les
ont forcées à les interrompre.
Mais c'est finalement la femme
du pilote qui a demandé de tout
arrêter, de peur que d'autres
personnes perdent la vie.
- Ils ont remonté plus...
beaucoup plus de pièces,
d'ailes, de parties de fuselage,
de moteurs, etc., de l'avion
de Leaper et moins de pièces
de l'avion de mon père.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Robert Hackett avait presque
5 ans au printemps 1951,
quand le drame est survenu.
70 ans plus tard, cette histoire
l'habite toujours.
- C'est comme fondamental
à mon... à mon psyché, tout ça.
- Oui.
- Alors, l'idée que le...
le fils cherche son père,
c'est... c'est profond.
L'avion de mon père serait
celui qui est plus au Nord.
- Il serait dans cette zone-là.
- Le capitaine Perreault a
identifié des cibles d'intérêt,
de quoi encourager sa petite
équipe, composée de ses
meilleurs élèves, à poursuivre
les recherches.
JEAN-MARC PERREAULT,
professeur de sciences
- Si on trouve quelque chose,
on ne touche rien. On n'a pas
le droit de toucher ni remonter
quoi que ce soit. Et l'armée
a une équipe spéciale
pour l'identification
des dépouilles de guerre
parmi les épaves,
donc on va passer le relais.
Des histoires comme ça, il faut
pas que ça tombe dans l'oubli.
J'essaie de réunir un fils
et son père. C'est vraiment ça
que je cherche à faire, là.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le capitaine n'a pas eu
de succès ce jour-là. Il espère
reprendre les recherches
avec des équipements plus
sophistiqués au printemps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je suis content
de vous rencontrer.
- Ah, oui! Bien, moi aussi.
- Grâce aux recherches
entreprises par Jean-Marc
Perreault, les Forces armées
canadiennes ont décidé
d'honorer, cette année,
la mémoire des pilotes disparus.
- J'inviterais maintenant
M. Robert Hackett, fils du chef
d'escadrille Hackett,
à vous adresser la parole.
- Les restes sont là depuis le
31 mars 1951, quand son avion de
chasse et celui de son collègue
Robert Leaper ont heurté
le fleuve de plein fouet.
C'est une étape majeure,
majeure et tout à fait
inattendue, hein.
- Robert Hackett réfléchit
à ce qu'il fera si on retrouve
un jour les restes de son père :
les retirer pour les inhumer...
... ou les laisser sur place,
au fond de l'eau, en tout
respect pour la mémoire de son
cher père, pilote téméraire.
- C'est important de dire :
"Face à ta tombe, je te salue,
mon père."